what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm waren Thompson
and today Jonathan major was supposed to
receive his sentencing he was found
guilty in the trial against his
ex-girlfriend Grace Jabari who claimed
he assaulted her and charged several
cases of assault against him he was
found guilty of two of the four cases
and they claimed that he could get up to
a year in prison and today we were
supposed to find out his sentencing
however it got pushed back it has been
delayed now we do have a new sentencing
date and since this has all happened
there have been a lot of Articles coming
out from legal experts talking about
whether or not they think he's going to
get jail time or not and also some
articles have come out on whether or not
they believe Jonathan major can recover
from this as an actor if he can return
to Hollywood after being found guilty on
accounts of third degree assault and
harassment but Jonathan major is
fighting back which is why the
sentencing scene that was supposed to be
today has been postponed so let's dive
into this and talk about what it means
for the future of Jonathan Majors
whether or not he could return to acting
and return to the role of King the
Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe at Marvel Studios so although
the sentencing did not happen today and
has been pushed back we now have the new
date of when the sentencing is going to
take place according to deadline that is
going to take place on April 8th so it's
been delayed by 2 months and there is a
reason that it was delayed and that is
because Jonathan major and his legal
team filed a motion to set aside the
verdict which can be filed under New
York law after a conviction but before
sentencing he filed this on Monday night
so last night February 5th so this is
essentially Jonathan Major's appealing
the decision that found him guilty a
motion to set aside a judgment which is
what Jonathan Major's filed is an
application to overturn or set aside a
Court's judgment verdict or other final
ruling in a casee typically this motion
is proposed by a party who is
dissatisfied with the result of a case
which obviously Jonathan major is he was
found guilty when he has consistently
claimed that he is innocent now this
isn't an actual appeal but it is very
similar and back in the interview that
was released by Good Morning America
Jonathan major did state that he was
indeed going to appeal the Court's
decision and the motion to set aside
judgment is basically doing that but
what happens if the judge decides to not
do that and they decide to issue the
sentencing well the District Attorney's
office has until March 5th to respond to
the motion and according to deadline.com
judge gaffy said today in court that he
intends to make a ruling on the defense
motion by April 1st which is April
Fool's Day which is kind of ironic I
doubt he would joke around with his
ruling but still ironic but that is a
week before the actual sentencing now
there's some good and bad news when it
comes to the future of Jonathan major
the good news is it looks like Jonathan
major won't face any jail time most
legal analysts and lawyers who have
spoken up about this pretty much state
that since it's his first conviction
they probably won't give him jail time
Carrie London a civil rights and
criminal defense attorney at Schulman
and Hill in Manhattan said this since
it's the defendant's first conviction
although technically he faces one year
of jail the judge will 99% give him 3
years probation anger management and
possibly some community service Mr major
is not getting jail time so that's good
it is his first conviction and basically
what they decided with the two accounts
they found him guilty of was Reckless
assault in the third degree and a
harassment in the second degree which
means he did not intend to hurt Grace
Jabari he did so via Reckless Behavior
so even the Court ruled that it's not
like Jonathan major set out to hurt her
he just did so by accident but he still
hurt her nonetheless so they found him
guilty of the two charges so great news
he probably is not going to jail he'll
have to do a little bit of community
service anger management and will be on
probation but of course the big question
is well what does that mean for his
career well there was an article done by
the Los Angeles Times talking about all
of the deals that he has now lost
including being fired from Disney we'll
go over those in a bit but they also
talk about how he did what they refer to
as a terrible job with PR after he was
found guilty speaking of those ABC News
Good Morning America interviews that he
did after they start out by talking
about the chair of African and
africanamerican studies department at
Duke University Mark Anthony Neil about
how he said that Jonathan Majors is done
and that he knew he was in trouble they
state that like Legions of fans and
critics impressed by Major's muscular
performances in the last black man in
San Francisco Creed 3 HBO's Lovecraft
country and other projects Neil feared
it was a stunning setback for for a
talented black actor who seemed to be on
the brink of breakthrough stardom and
given the long history of racist tropes
about black male sexuality in America he
knew the case would be inflicted by the
fact that Jabari is white Neil stated my
immediate response was he's done it was
a bad look considering not only the
culture at large but also thinking about
how black Americans would respond I felt
it would be difficult for him to
navigate the situation they then State
the aftermath of what has happened since
Jonathan major was accused of this and
since he has been found guilty they
state in the aftermath of his arrest
major had already suffered serious
career damage losing his management and
public relations firm as well as ad
campaigns with the US Army and the Texas
Rangers baseball team but the Fallout
after a New York jury in December found
him guilty on two of four counts was
particularly Swift and brutal Disney
fired Majors from his role as super
villain King the Conqueror in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he was cut from a
film about basketball star Dennis Rodman
and magazine dreams which had sparked
early Oscar buzz for Majors after it
premiered at the 2023 Sundance Film
Festival is in limbo after being dropped
by distributor search light pictures and
the chair of the African and
African-American studies department at
Duke University Mark Anthony Neil and
others say it's the actor's
postconviction behavior that hurt him
the most casting doubts on his ability
to repair his reputation once his legal
troubles are behind him Nathan Miller
the founder and CEO of Miller Inc a Los
angeles-based strategic Communications
and crisis management firm stated
Jonathan made a bad situation worse one
PR failure after another when talking
about the Good Morning America interview
they talked about when he was asked
about how jabari's injuries happened in
which he replied with I wish to God I
knew Miller stated that interview
tremendously undercut his credibility
there's ways of denying you committed
physical assault but also acknowledging
the complexities of the situation that
shows responsibility the public doesn't
like it when they think someone is being
evasive and makes themselves a victim
then veteran entertainment manager and
publicist Raman hervey the second stated
that interview was a really bad mistake
it was irrelevant because he was already
convicted it was also ill timed it was
not going to change the public
perception of him at a time he really
needed to be away from the media and wa
his sentencing the article even goes on
to state that some people think that his
current girlfriend actor Megan Good is
simply for show during a segment of the
two black girls one rose pop culture
podcast Natasha Scott Rachel declared
that this is such a farce referring to
Jonathan major and Megan Good's
relationship and the fact that she was
always there by his side in court and in
the interview and he specifically
mentioned her in the interview
speculation swirled around them with
people suggesting that the relation ship
was a setup to boost support for Majors
among black fans and again Mark Anthony
Neil said the chair of the African and
africanamerican studies department at
Duke University I quote there was
clearly a team of fixers trying to get
him past this situation with the black
community he seems to be a black actor
who was not particularly interested in
black women end quote so unfortunately
right now it seems like there is a lot
going against Jonathan major as far as
the public opinion is concerned but I
would love to hear your thoughts about
this what do you think about Jonathan
Major's at this point in time in the
Good Morning America interview Jonathan
major said that he wants to return as an
actor to Hollywood of course and that he
hopes people will give him a second
chance he most likely is not going to
get any jail time at all which is a good
thing but would Hollywood rehire him
after some time passes by Time Heals all
but what would everybody think about
that please leave your thoughts and
comments about this in the comment
section down below to stay up to date on
this situation but mostly the Marvel
Cinematic Universe be sure to subscribe
to the channel so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos we are also
giving away a PS5 and Xbox series X some
Marvel Legends items and some DC items
to enter all you have to do is subscribe
and leave a comment down below we pick
one winner at the end of every single
month and the winner picks one item you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof